Jordan Patel: Today’s focus: schema evolution for orders.
Noah Williams: Any blockers from last time?
Riley Chen: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Noah Williams: From QA perspective, Tests should cover unhappy paths.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on schema evolution for orders; ship a thin slice.
Samira López: Risk: flaky tests for schema evolution for orders.
Noah Williams: Action: create test plan.
Riley Chen: Risk: data migration for schema evolution for orders.
Noah Williams: Let’s clarify acceptance criteria on schema evolution for orders.
Samira López: From design side, Security review is likely.
Priya Singh: From QA perspective, Performance baseline needs to be recorded.
Riley Chen: Risk: data migration for schema evolution for orders.
Samira López: Risk: data migration for schema evolution for orders.
Samira López: I think we split schema evolution for orders into two subtasks.
Samira López: Let’s clarify acceptance criteria on schema evolution for orders.
Riley Chen: Action: book design review.
Priya Singh: Action: write migration.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on schema evolution for orders; start with a spike.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on schema evolution for orders; parallelize testing.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on schema evolution for orders; parallelize testing.
Jordan Patel: From QA perspective, We will stage it behind a feature flag.
Riley Chen: My take is we split schema evolution for orders into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on schema evolution for orders; start with a spike.
Riley Chen: I think we split schema evolution for orders into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: From design side, We will stage it behind a feature flag.
Samira López: Let’s not block on schema evolution for orders; start with a spike.
Avery Kim: Any risks we’re missing? on schema evolution for orders.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on schema evolution for orders; parallelize testing.
Avery Kim: My take is we split schema evolution for orders into two subtasks.
Samira López: From design side, We can chunk work behind a ticket.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on schema evolution for orders; ship a thin slice.
Avery Kim: My take is we split schema evolution for orders into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: Observability dashboards for errors on schema evolution for orders.
Samira López: Let’s capture action items clearly on schema evolution for orders.
Jordan Patel: From QA perspective, Security review is likely.
Riley Chen: From design side, Design feedback is pending.
Avery Kim: Risk: data migration for schema evolution for orders.
Avery Kim: Quick update on the scope on schema evolution for orders.
Priya Singh: Action: book design review.
Jordan Patel: Coordinate with SRE for rollout on schema evolution for orders.
Riley Chen: Action: book design review.
Avery Kim: Okay, who can take ownership?
Avery Kim: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Noah Williams: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.